foreign
[Applause]
this is the aftermath of fighting
between shayad groups in the center of
Basra
[Music]
militants Affiliated to influential
leader muktada Sada exchanged fire with
a splinter group backed by Iran
both sides suffered casualties
at night armed people started to gather
here intense gunfire went on machine
guns anti-aircraft weapons even the
children were screaming people were
afraid in their homes cars broke apart
all the houses here were impacted by
gunfire
there was firing we woke up terrified
the area here had become a front line
God is our witness Basra turned into
muscle
the car was impacted it burned this one
broke apart over there a shop burned
even our homes were hit our children
kept screaming
is Iraq's main oil producing Hub and
this escalation in violence follows
fighting in Baghdad on Monday
the political crisis pits followers of
the powerful shayad political leader
muktada Sada against mostly iran-aligned
parties and parliamentary groups
Southern supporters emerged as the
biggest party in Parliament in elections
in October but weren't able to form a
government
Iraq has had a caretaker government ever
since
in Baghdad the Supreme Court has
postponed rolling on a petition filed by
sadri's movement until next Wednesday it
demands that the solution of Parliament
and early elections
but this agreement between the political
Rivals goes beyond that
Baghdad